ihr seht schon ich sitze und das
bedeutet dass wir heute mal wieder auf
eine hilf mir folge reagiere be cool rap
in europa außer rand und band fragt
einfach nicht die folge schon zwei jahre
alt und ich habe mir auch schon einen
kleinen teil des videos bereits vor
langer zeit in dem live stream
angeschaut allerdings noch nicht alles
und ich weiß auch nur noch dass es um
irgend so ein quatsch opa geht also wir
schauen direkt rein
[Musik]
wann das bitte gerade für ein high five
hat sie gar der erst gesagt hat wie seid
ihr nicht mal ganz verrückt oder was
sprachenlernen babbel psychische die oma
damals gestorben ist doch das alles lob
psychisch seine enkelin eine verbrannte
geschrieben und einzig wenn ihr darüber
sprechen wollte der ist einfach
abgehauen hier gelandet
und jetzt feiert die enkelin mit ihrem
open house party pics gerückt
ich werde auch hier eingeladen worden
weil jedoch nicht geschehen er musste
nach hause sagt auch nicht länger
bleiben
ich hab das erlaubt ich mir schließlich
der passiert ja der oper ist ja hier der
boss
ich bin der boss ich habe es erlaubt
was schaue ich mir heute schon wieder an
ich habe euch auf instagram gefragt ob
ich heute hilf mir oder ebay feld
hochladen soll und damals leider haben
niemals eine fünfte abgestimmt von daher
sehen wir jetzt da wo wir sind
[Musik]
ich
die hätte ich auch gern so ein opa aber
irgendwie auch überhaupt nicht und ich
verstehe jetzt da kommen
okay die mutter dann scheint stress mit
der tochter und die tochter flüchtete
deswegen zum opa
denn nicht
was
geht da gerade ab das ist sind die
mutter wieder da ist meister
ich
ich frage mich schon lange gar nichts
mehr
so hat sich der opa ein paar
interessante bildchen aufgegangen
auch hierauf hängen was ich will dass
mein haus nein das kannst du ja auch mal
am energie ist 60 soll
megi ist 16
die sieht fast genauso alt wie ihre
ausgaben stimmen sicher nicht mit nach
hause ich werde hier bleiben und wenn du
das noch mal tagt dann schicke ich dir
das jugendamt und heizen da kannst du
mich hin
das
eskaliert gerade extrem krass du wissen
recht hier spaß trennen
[Musik]
der sommer böse wörter hier die tür
bitte hinter dir zu ich nicht nochmal
hören
am nächsten tag was ist europa knut hat
noch lange nicht genug
opa knut hat noch lange nicht genug
ab zum sport ihr ziel hat ich finde erst
mal einen erotik kurs ich kann auch
meine beine wieder bewegen wollte meine
megamind ist meine enkeltochter die
haben mich aber dieselbe der
eventbereich
die oecd sieht sie noch zu haben
ich sitze noch zu haben du bist doppelt
so alt knoten ich sitze jetzt wird sie
gerne und die prämie zu hoch seien
jetzt macht er da wie gestützt das ist
ja der mann der 70 und schafft mehr als
ich und ich habe ich noch nie gesehen
meine enkel nie auf die idee gebracht
der superminister der zwischen gisela
und knut
ja zur kasse geben jeden tag acht sein
prof ich bin ja auch nicht das alte
eisen da kommt höre ich auch nicht zum 1
falls jemand interesse hatten der knut
ist überhaupt nicht das alte eisen ich
glaube ich werde hier dauer da kann ich
jedem dach nette mädels beobachtet und
auch ein bisschen jetzt hat einer dieser
schikane kann mich noch daran erinnern
da hat er der hat egal ist schaut
einfach selbst ein stück
er ist halt nicht mal kohle drauf ich
glaube das war doch ein bisschen
was geht da gerade
[Musik]
wieder zu dem star jetzt muss ich aber
gehen jetzt wurde ihr erster
ich wünschte ich hätte
ebay fels hochgeladen am nächsten tag
europa knut ist hier
[Musik]
gut
wer hat dich war der rentner will
endlich berühmt werden
jetzt fängt er nämlich an zu rappen den
part würdig
springen okay es geht los was geht ab
hier kommt mcu bugueño
ramsey oper lulu knut geht es noch
weiter
hier ist super knoten tut mir super gut
rappen
geschrieben so tut oper com weiter
passiert so lange im ruhestand
aha jetzt nämlich die sache geht joggen
gartenzaunes offen besser
hat er ganz für mich nicht laufen
und ich dachte deutschrap ist gerade
ganz normal dann kommt europa knut und
setzt dem ganzen noch eine kirsche
obendrauf die ich das allerdings
selbstverständlich immer meine hilfe
reactions sage sind keine aussagen von
mir beleidigend gemeint oder richten
sich persönlich gegen die schauspieler
sondern es geht immer nur um die
geschauspielert rolle also hier die
personen hinter europa das glaube ich
eine extrem coole gut so aber die rolle
ob knut ist so fremd schämen
[Musik]
der bandenchef der chef von der bebop
chef von der bande knut das bist du das
war das geld was ich je gemacht habe da
werde ich auf meine alten tage noch
richtig beruf gehört ist richtig cool
knut
das hier ist das ist gerade sinnbildlich
für die für die komplette folge ich
frage mich aber was die mutter macht
kommt die noch mal da rein nur wenige
minuten später wenn man vom teufel
geredet
[Musik]
ich hab's euch zensiert aber das steht
über knut nackt im bad und rasiert sich
seine thermisch menschenrechte sind
ziemlich abstoßen wollen wir glaube ich
nicht sehen
die damenwelt schön sein und als rapper
will ich geld verdienen wie schon oben
bis unten
irgendwie ist ja süß
ich frage mich halt voll wie es sein
wird wenn ich später irgendwann
vielleicht mal opa bin und dann will ich
halt jung bleiben und cool sein für
meine enkelkinder ob ich dann auch ja
aber gut bei offen natürlich will ich
jetzt nicht mal warum schmerzt
opa knut hat jetzt noch eine fotosession
es grenzt an eine der schlimmsten hilfe
folgen die wir je hatten
s
es ist
wir sind mittlerweile schon nicht mehr
auf diesem planeten mit dem niveau
ist da was wir sind sogar schon
außerhalb der milchstraße an der stelle
ich das heute wieder ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
meine reaktion hierauf die hilfe folge
mit dem rappen in europa gut gefallen
hat dann das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem wir die hitler schreibt immer
und in die kommentare ob ihr gerne so
einen opa hätte man auf der einen seite
ist es cool er ist jung geblieben
auf der anderen seite vielleicht auch
ein bisschen die vorbildfunktion
verfehlt sage ich mal schreibt es mir
gerne in die kommentare jetzt befinden
uns allerdings auch im auto und die
findet hier oben ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr noch kein teil der news seite
noch nicht abonnent von meinem kanal
seid könnt ihr einfach kostenlos
draufklicken dann verpasse keine videos
mehr das mega geil weil ich halt richtig
geistreichen content hochladen und hier
ist ein anderer geistreicher content
verlinkt also kriegt da gern drauf
[Musik]